some parents don't realize what
babysitters don't know
okay so i'm gonna give you a couple
cards
to figure out if it's something you
handle yourself if you need a backup
adult or if you need to call 911.
the safe center is a program to teach
young teens and tweens
to be safe when they are babysitting
when you babysit someone you're in
charge of their life
[Music]
i'm ingrid and i'm 13 years old
one of the best parts of being 13 is
like independence up there is like
things that i don't play with anymore
they're like my old toys
i became interested in babysitting with
my younger brother
when my parents go out i do watch him
make sure he's not doing anything like
dangerous or anything that could get him
hurt
at dignity health there is a safe sitter
program
it's about like learning the dangers and
how to be prepared
all right well good morning you're gonna
be here all day and you're like what can
i possibly learn all day but you will be
surprised dignity health started this
program in 1995.
we've taught over 1100 kids and i've
been involved in teaching
the majority of those
how safe sarah got started what happened
is a child a toddler came into
the emergency room
and the child had choked the child had a
babysitter by the time they got the
child into the er the child died
the first job we tend to give kids is
babysitting
if we're going to give you that kind of
job we need to equip you to be able to
do that kind of job
how many of you are willing to change a
poopy diaper right now
they would love to be good babysitters
they don't necessarily know how
with safe sarah they are equipped to be
caregivers
is that going to be hard enough to move
that object out we need a big burst of
air the very most important thing we
teach about is choking
don't go
like this
there you go it's going to be scary when
you're doing it i'm going to be honest
with you
but you have to stay calm and you have
to do it it's nice to learn how to
actually do on like a mannequin but it
would definitely be difficult on a real
person but this is what you need to do
by teaching them what to do with choking
we're hoping that they never have to use
cpr
here we go
one one two three four five six before
the class i was thinking
babysitting this is more we play
together and i make sure they just don't
run off or do anything dangerous see
those chests go up good all right good
job you're done then after the class
ingrid i'm thinking there's way more
things that could happen
while babysitting a kid
now i do feel more confident
hey
i'm gonna be gone probably about an hour
i love you
you wanna go start playing
we are empowering our community
careful
we are
teaching our community
to care
with skills
[Music]
and so to me
that's all part of human kindness
[Music]
you